ae
[Música]
bem a história começa em padre miguel
rio de janeiro onde nasci onde minha
família escolheu que nascesse logo novo
com dois anos de idade a gente mudou
para campo 50 casas uma proposta de
emprego no meu pai para melhorar de vida
a gente foi pintar eu do rio chegando lá
passando três anos após essa mudança
ainda sem estabilidade financeira porque
o emprego do meu pai que prometer que
meu pai não chegou então o algo que eu
revidei ele foi fantástico que é poder
saber se haverá algumas coisas logo três
anos após em chegar quando tinha cinco
anos de idade no rio
meu pai morreu em um acidente de carro
a minha estabilizada ficou
desestabilizado aconteceu várias coisas
nesse período infantil da minha vida mas
sempre após a morte do meu pai sempre
foi uma criança muito introspectiva
sempre fechada
eu sempre fiquei trancado no meu mundo
imaginário da minha mente
adorava assistir dragon ball essas
coisas desse tipo de criança queria ser
super-herói salvar vidas
o tempo foi passando saber se vai
crescendo vai percebendo que aquele
mundo que você achava que poderia
acontecer não vai acontecendo
o pai que foi o trabalho não volta mais
e a ficha vai caindo então a partir daí
começa o desafio
a primeira coisa que falaram pra mim
após a morte do meu pai não foi um
consolo foi agora você é o homem da casa
a primeira atitude que eu tive quando me
falaram isso foi pegar uma gilete tenta
fazer a barba
cortei um pouco mas aprendi que seu nome
da casa não era só fazer a barba né
então aquela responsabilidade sempre
ficou na minha cabeça minha família
sempre preocupada com o futuro sempre me
comparando o meu pai sempre me
comparando a pessoa que ele era e todo
mundo me via nele
isso criou uma pressão muito grande mas
com o tempo vou me enturmando vou me
pegando amizades
fui crescendo solto mais na rua não
tinha tanta liberdade quando pequeno mas
foi crescendo então fui soltando mais
era bem marcado eu fui soltando para os
poucos por causa do trauma
minha irmã também ela ficava muito
preocupada então de marcava espaços na
rua quase a idade foi chegando a
liberdade foi crescendo
minha mãe sempre sonhou em colocar ela
pra tocar alguma coisa sabe ela sempre
achou bonito e tal
queria tocar saxofone aí tudo bem só que
eu tentava entrar na música não gostava
não queria não era bom e aquilo nunca me
agradava com a idade crescendo cheguei a
um ponto que foi olhando as pessoas na
rua não tinha meu lado paternal então
certas questões da minha vida foi
apreendida pelos meus colegas
vendo a atitude deles e imitava chegou
um tempo na minha vida adolescência que
minha mãe vendo o andar da carruagem em
relação aos meus colegas da rua que que
tinha uma certa malandragem é mais uma
malandragem carioca só um pouquinho além
do normal
então minha mãe vendo aquele perigo
iminente e falou assim não vou ter que
preocupar
vou colocar você na música não queria de
jeito nenhum
não queria colocar na música achava
chato eu tinha tentado duas vezes eu não
queria não era bom
todo mundo que entrava se destacava - eu
e minha mãe falou não tem um projeto que
está dando uma bolsa você vai tentar
entrar lá que você consegue chegar lá
nem escolheu um instrumento pude chegou
um cara chamado maçã e falou assim você
vai tocar contrabaixo
eu não quero clarineta não vai tocar
contrabaixo eu tá com o instrumento e
mostrou
aí pronto não quero não vai dar certo é
muito grande é caro
não quero aqui não há uma semana mas por
que você quer que eu toco contrabaixo
hoje o tamanho das suas canelas vai
ficar enorme e eu não era tão grande
então olha vou tocar uma semana
fiquei né e chegando nesse período de
música sabe o período é muito diferente
a música é um universo paralelo pra quem
gosta de universos cinematográficas
existe um universo decide se o homa
vegetal ea história existe ali
em paralelo e às vezes a gente quando tá
assistindo esse tipo de filme a gente
imagina como se fosse realidade sabe
daqui a pouco vai passar o toque o
martelo fim do ano a gente e na música
quase isso é quase isso
no período da música estava lá e mesmo
ganhando aquele universo que a galera se
divertindo era muito mais gente do que
antes
aquela aquela alegria sabe e um
destacável é o pior da turma sabe não
tinha
chega um momento na minha vida que deu
aquele estalo um estado diferente
eu estava tocando uma música chamada
poeta o camponês do compositor chamado
suppé e de repente a partir de uma nota
minha vida mudou essa nota é um momento
paralelo a um paixão
quando você chega e sabe que você está
amando alguém quando você olha nos olhos
pode um detalhe da boca ea partir
daquilo ali a sua vida não é mais a
mesma
um segundo atrás era um jeito o segundo
à frente era outro completamente
diferente ea partir dali
minha vida mudou completamente eu estava
força na música já ficava o dia todo no
projeto já não ficava já saía da escola
direto pra lá eu não queria saber mais
nada só queria o projeto só queria tocar
saber eu me sentia completo
sabe aquela ideia de criança de sentir
super herói
aquela ideia bem dragão bose mesmo sabe
você é fraco você é uma classe ruim sabe
ninguém quer
você não é da classe dos príncipes
você não tem família com dinheiro para
te dar um instrumento
você não tem nada disso mas com seu
esforço você pode e eu me sentia um meio
com super saiyajin sabe eu fui tentando
evoluir de forma forma é difícil é um
instrumento meio ingrato às vezes mas a
gente ama e com o tempo passando a gente
chegou a um ponto que eu não estava mais
querendo mais nada na minha vida só
tocar sabe me perguntavam o que eu
queria da vida como homem da casa sabe
aquele menino que precisava com o filho
de quatro filhos eu era o único eu sou o
único homem então fica uma coisa assim
você precisa de uma formação mas eu tô
fazendo música para a hipótese de
formação
vamos lá chegou 18 anos a idade crucial
para o garoto adolescente pobre a idade
que você precisa trabalhar
não importa importa o que você quer se
vai demorar um ano ou dois
você precisa ter uma formação
profissional mas eu tô fazendo música eu
quero ser músico não mas você precisa
ter algo seguro
você precisa ter certeza das coisas você
precisa ter algo que vai te dar
segurança financeira
tá vamos lá a primeira coisa que eu fiz
após sair da escola entrei numa fábrica
de móveis escolares
não importava o emprego pra mim porque
era o único emprego que me dava
oportunidade de continuar tocando então
não importa que hora que eu ia fazer o
que eu ia fazer tom vai poder trabalhar
vou ver amanhã qual é uniforme em sua
roupa beleza vem entrar na fábrica
tranqüilo aquele lugar parecia um
submundo sabe bem assombroso no primeiro
dia já tomei uma queimadura de segundo
grau no braço foi todo manchado de tinta
na cara passava dentro na lista ea tinta
na mão assim sabe mas era terrível
o banheiro é um buraco surgiu no chão
que você precisava aí que não tinha
nenhuma passagem de vento e perto disso
tudo eu não estava importando com nada
porque eu conseguir jogar um lugar que
eu tinha como dar conta para a sociedade
que eu tinha um emprego e eu poderia
tocar um instrumento
chegou um ponto que quando eu saí do
emprego porque eu consegui uma vaga como
ajudante na secretaria ainda ganhar
dinheiro então a sociedade não pegava no
meu pé até o momento
então sair da fábrica sair da fábrica já
feliz da vida né porque já estava já
estava me atrapalhando fisicamente a
fábrica então ocorreu um risco talvez
não tocar mais conseguir sair da fábrica
trabalhou como ajudante na secretaria de
uma de um projeto social que pra mim eu
tenho um amor muito grande que é a
questão da vida
lá eles abriram a porta para mim e lá eu
consegui ver o mundo de outra forma
me doeu máximo sabe me deram essa bolsa
com uma forma de poder mantê la
acreditar em mim
chegou em 2009 aos 19 anos a minha
professora teve que se ausentar
ela tem que seguir a carreira sabe o dia
chegou para ela então me colocaram como
um professor de contrabaixo monitor
eu encarei aquilo como um desafio porque
sempre achei lindo
a idéia é ser professor e eu olhei
aquilo lhe falei pô vou agarrar essa fui
agarrei eu achava mágico a idéia de tali
da aula a pessoa não sabe nada e de
repente a partir de você ela sabe alguma
coisa
isso me encanta até hoje passou um tempo
2008 2009 ea pressão da sociedade
continuava
só que como estava ganhando dinheiro
conseguia né comprar a ideia passou um
tempo ver a turnê da bolívia da
orquestra mágico conseguiria ainda por
aí
sou músico mas pelo menos a viagem foi
pra fora não foi legal
a eventual nova iorque pronto nessa
tentação total
agora ninguém vai pegar no meu pé mais
afp nova york pouco né
se fui para nova york você não foi ontem
na falar mesmo
até aí tudo bem chega 2012
eu achava que não ia ter essa pressão
chegou 2012 a pressão estava muito
grande para você vai fazer 22 anos e
você não tem formação eu o que eu sempre
tive um problema com a auto estima e
auto estima baixa atrapalhou muito no
desenvolvimento musical
eu achava que o interior do rio e não é
ter vaga em faculdade na área isso
sempre me atrapalhou
então quando chegou em 2002 eu me olhei
falei realmente talvez tenha razão
eu parei para o instrumento deixei no
canto mas antes de sair do projeto o
marcos que me colocou no contrabaixo e
falou você não vai conseguir sair eu
estou saindo agora não há música você
está com a doença da música foi embora
me arrependi amargamente foi um dos
pontos mais triste da minha vida eu não
consegui viver direito
eu estava fazendo dedilhado sabino cabo
de vassoura tinha uma aluna minha fazer
isso quando estava nas férias
sabe eu não aguentava mais chegou um
ponto que eu falei 'não não aguenta
eu vou eu vou voltar pra tocar você vai
voltar a tocar voo mas eu prometo que eu
faço o curso eu vou prometeu eu vou
voltar mas eu faço um curso de alguma
coisa sabe profissão
aí eu fui e voltei a me sentir um
bandido nem sentiu não moral está
voltando a tocar né
voltei em 2013 parece até uma praga
chegou em 2014
antes de antes dessa dessa minha
transição teve a turnê para portugal mas
nem por agora né massa final de 2013
só que chega em 2014 a prefeitura cortou
o patrocínio e agora só vamos receber a
praga de novo volta você é um qualquer
na sociedade novo desempregado músico
mais conhecido pelos conservadores como
vagabundo
então eu comecei em qualquer meio que
aparecia qualquer coisa que aparecer na
minha reta eu já estava agora pedreiro
palhaço
nossa foi um dos melhores foi o palhaço
que eu fui eu foi um monstro no
labirinto então miss a se assustar as
pessoas mas mesmo assim eu fiz aquilo
pelo dinheiro para conseguir um festival
de música das pessoas estava para
conseguir dinheiro para ser um trabalho
não é tudo pra música tudo fachada
quem precisa de dinheiro né 2015
essa pressão voltou de novo empate mais
uma vez
dessa vez foi cumprir a promessa de
fazer um curso administração
vou trabalhar com acidente iniciativa
isso aí eu sou bonita tabela por essa me
afundei me afundei porque a música que
eu quero aparecer uma oportunidade
trabalhar com música de novo coração fez
aquela casquinha sabe embora trabalhe
com música cardoso moreira parecia uma
prefeitura
quando acabou o ano voltou aquele
problema de patrocínio não vai renovar o
meu deus que eu faço na minha vida saber
eu fiquei apavorado de novo vou ter que
largar até que apareceu um convite pra
mim esse convite foi pra ver como eu já
conhecia o neojibá conhecer alguns
músicos mas eu não conhecer a fundo
nesse meio tempo quando tentava receber
um pouco disse que estava recebendo esse
convite de si mesma pessoa que me
colocou no contrabaixo sabe que me falou
que eu estava com a doença da música
ele mandou esse convite pra mim eu
fiquei pensativo falei com minha noiva
estava perto de casar só que eu tinha
que tomar uma decisão em semanas para
receber para conseguir assimilar e tal
só que tinha que decidir logo você vai
para vitória da conquista
eu nunca saí do sudeste então do sudeste
pra cima então pra mim meu deus do céu
eu achei que eu cheguei aqui todo mundo
nunca a poeira no pelourinho então
mas nada disso aí o povo e que eu faço
exportar meio grogue falou am
ana eu e meu deus o que eu faço beleza
nesse meio tempo recebi a notícia que um
colega meu da trompa tinha falecido
o marlon criado na periferia como eu
devia da música como eu
só que a visão dele era diferente sabe a
música conseguiu segurá lo até o ponto
de lhe ser ficar num lugar onde não
deveria ser confundido com um bandido
por causa da cor da pele dele por causa
da marginalidade por causa das amizades
dele depois que perdeu o patrocínio ele
ficou de bico e bico e foi assassinada e
quando falaram pra mim pra vitória
conquista eu pensei nossa embora vou
aceitar esse desafio
cheguei aqui sem rumo sem conhecer
ninguém nada deixei a minha futura
esposa em casa e fui pra cá cá sozinho
num lugar completamente diferente de
onde vivia quando cheguei aqui poucos
meses depois que eu cheguei encontrei
com o ricardo castro ac tal meio folgado
sem fazer saber o que estava fazendo
ricardo uma percepção maravilhosa chegou
pra mim você precisa conhecer o neojibá
mas eu já conheço não você precisa
conhecer o novo ba
visite os lucros conheça o samba beleza
e cor à minha cabeça está até hoje
e eu digo pra vocês que é maravilhoso
a filosofia do nesv aprendi que ensina a
cada dia que você aprende
você cresce você depende daquilo sabe e
voltou crescendo a cada dia com isso mas
uma coisa me encanta a cada dia me
encanta na apresentação deles a cada dia
eu vejo alunos que antes não tinham
perspectiva com perspectiva grande
hoje eu vejo crianças que eram para ser
marginalizados pela sociedade assim como
eu era
tocando sabe você vê crianças que
estavam sem as vezes sem poder ir pra
aula porque choveu o rio encheu e não
tem como atravessar
os locais mais terríveis do mundo e eu
acredito que a gente pode transformar a
vida dessas pessoas com a música assim
como a minha vida foi transformada hoje
os meus amigos da rua estão mortos e um
sobrevivente través da música e eu
acredito que a gente pode mudar a vida
de muita gente
a gente pode mudar a vida de cada um
través da música mas eu deixo para vocês
uma reflexão porque eu tenho que me
preocupar com a manhã porque o meu
trabalho não é uma profissão porque não
sou honrado por fazer o trabalho que eu
faço o que eu preciso ter uma formação
para provar à sociedade que eu sou capaz
de alguma coisa
[Música]
veja só
[Aplausos]